hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast population genomics
screening the Alabama genomic health
initiative it is presented by Bruce Korf
MD PhD dr. Cerf is a professor of
genetics and chief genomics officer at
UAB medicine I'm Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
get begin I would like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located any
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Cerf I will now turn the presentation
over to him well thank you very much
pleased to have the opportunity to
describe the Alabama genomic health
initiative the project that we have been
working on over about the past year and
a half I'm here at University of Alabama
at Birmingham and with our collaborators
at Hudson Alpha Institute for
biotechnology the overall objectives of
the project are first of all to
determine whether genomic screening can
be deployed on a population wide basis
to ask the question how can we return
results I mean by that medically
important results to participants to
better understand what the community
expects from participation in such an
endeavor and finally to look at the
outcomes how can we measure whether we
are actually providing a service that's
both needed and appreciated as I
mentioned a moment ago the project is a
collaboration between ume medicine and
HudsonAlpha
Institute for biotechnology in
Huntsville Alabama it was funded by 2
million dollar allocations in fiscal
year 17 and 18 in each year and we're
hoping that this will be a five-year
project that will be funded by the state
the overall goal is to provide genomic
analysis for about 10,000 citizens of
the state of Alabama over a five year
span to return specific clinical data
which I'll describe in some detail and
also to maintain both the research
database and a biobank as the project
began to come together which was in
about October of 2016 the first steps
were to establish an oversight committee
and this includes leaders both at UAB
and at HudsonAlpha
the principal investigators besides
myself or Greg Barcia at HudsonAlpha and
Matt might at UAB then we establish
these five working groups one on
bioethics intended to guide us in terms
of ethical legal and social implications
of the project and also in the formation
of the informed consent process and the
IRB protocol a data and bioinformatics
working group to focus on data
management the sample preparation bio
banking and overall support of research
applications of the data an education
working group to provide resources for
participant education and outreach
genetic counseling
individuals who receive medically
important results and how these are
communicated both to the participants
and to providers in addition also a CME
program for providers and genomics
working group that has really set the
paradigm for us both in genotyping and
sequencing and also to do the annotation
of results that we'll be returning to
participants and finally a participant
and provider engagement working group
intended to provide recruitment and
engagement activities as well as
outreach into the community
I guess one fundamental question is is
why do this
what is if you will the value
proposition to the various stakeholders
well for the participants we are
returning results of the 59 currently 59
genes on the American College of medical
genetics and genomics list that was
developed actually for secondary
findings now go into more detail about
that in a few minutes and also there is
a group where we're doing sequencing to
achieve a diagnosis to end the
diagnostic Odyssey is it's called for
those who have undiagnosed phenotypes so
we believe there is a return of value to
participants from the perspective of
health providers this is an opportunity
to educate them about the application of
genomic medicine in their practice and
also to provide support for their
patients who actually have findings for
the research community it provides
access to both genotypic and link
medical information to get a snapshot of
genomic data for the Alabama population
and to also provide a platform for
research on ethical legal and social
issues just the process of engagement of
the community and finally from the
perspective of the state we aim to
provide a kind of genomics ready
population and healthcare workforce
there is a potential for economic
development based on
this activity and providing a sort of
cutting edge perception for the interest
and readiness of the state to be a
player in the area of genomic medicine
well this is a complicated timeline that
covers from when the project was funded
in October of 2016
over its first year as we were getting
the infrastructure in place I'm not
going to go into detail here probably
the main point of this slide is to
highlight how many moving parts there
are to this ranging from town hall
meetings to get input from the community
about the most appropriate way to
proceed to shepherding the protocol
through the UAB IRB so that we were
approved to proceed with the project
there was a press conference snapshot of
which was shown at the upper left and we
actually began pilot enrollment in May
of 2017 I'm deliberately paused for a
month or so just to make sure that our
workflows we're going as they should and
began kind of full recruitment in July
of 2017 and that's been going on ever
since now two separate cohorts are being
recruited for participation in this
study we call them the population cohort
and the affected cohort now the
population cohort are adults not
selected for any particular medical
problems literally this is any adult who
is able to give consent it need to be in
Alabama resident given that that's where
the support is coming from but we're not
targeting any particular kind of medical
situations and really just any adult
willing the affected cohort in contrast
our individuals who have a phenotype
that suggests the possibility of a
genetic etiology that has been resistant
to standard diagnostic testing
individuals in the population cohort of
genotyping
using the Illumina global screening
array about which I'll say more in just
a moment
variant analysis is done and there's a
return of results so-called medically
actionable variants of return to that
point also in just a moment
these are verified by Sanger sequencing
in a CLIA certified laboratory then
genetic counseling is provided to the
participants found to have pathogenic or
likely pathogenic variants in this list
of genes and then we help to connect
them to supportive care individuals in
the affected cohort have full genome
sequencing done at HudsonAlpha the goal
is to identify pathogenic variants in
fact we return pathogenic likely
pathogenic and we will return variants
of unknown significance that have at
least a plausible link to the disorder
recognizing of course that those are not
verified as being pathogenic and
similarly similarly provide genetic
counseling in supportive care meanwhile
DNA is saved in a tissue bank as well as
well as blood samples we also maintain a
genomic database all with an opt-in
consent I might add the medical record
information is linked through I to B 2
so the mainstay of genotyping is the
Illumina global screening array which
includes somewhere in the range of
600,000 single nucleotide variants
it covers relatively common variants as
well as enrichment for variants
identified in clinvar being pathogenic
responsible for Mendelian disorders
we're estimating something close to 50%
of the ACMG 59 list that I'll show you
in just a few moments are identified by
this approach but we certainly also
understand that at least 50% are not
identified an important point will
return to you there are some
pharmacogenomic variants that are
included and we may eventually return
these although for this point in time
we're only returning gains on the ACMG
59 list the whole genome sequencing is
done of ad HudsonAlpha with 30x mean
coverage and there is an option to
return incidental findings if the
participants choose to have that
information this is a list of the 59
genes on the ACMG list that is probably
familiar to most people now needs to be
remembered that this list was actually
put together in the context of clinical
sequencing and the kind of fundamental
principle here was that if you're doing
clinical sequencing these are genes that
are associated with high penetrance
so-called medically actionable disorders
which means these are disorders where if
a pathogenic variant is found in a gene
that there is a high probability of
developing a significant phenotype that
is amenable to intervention to achieve a
better outcome than if an individual had
waited to develop signs and symptoms
that would have led to a diagnosis there
are these 59 genes obviously multiple
variants that are pathogenic more likely
pathogenic within these genes they can
be bend into these classes of tumor
suppressor predisposition genes
um brca1 and 2 probably the best known
genes for relief from ET syndrome
various forms of Lynch syndrome and then
a variety of other probably less common
disorders associated with tumor
predisposition there are a set of genes
associated with connective tissue
dysplasia reason for those being on the
list as they can present with sudden
death potentially due to aortic
dissection a set of genes associated
with cardiomyopathy or cardiac
arrhythmia a few metabolic disorders
including hypercholesterolemia one might
imagine that that's easily diagnosed by
testing cholesterol but in fact
identifying an individual at genetic
risk and sometimes predate the
identification
I'm through cholesterol testing and then
two genes associated with malignant
hypothermia probably the one pharmaco
genetic variant one set of
pharmacogenetic variants on this list
because of the risk of very severe
adverse reactions to specific anesthetic
agents you need to remember that this
list first of all is a kind of a living
document there continues to be a
committee considering addition or
potentially even removal of genes from
this list and so it's likely that this
list will change over time and our plan
is to sort of keep up with it as we go
forward and again to emphasize this was
really not put together specific to
population screening or to research but
we felt it was a reasonably well vetted
list of disorders that would be a value
to participants if these results were
returned the communications that take
place within this program are both to
participants and to providers
participants of course will be informed
about the study and asked to provide
informed consent they have various
opt-in options including to receive the
results to have the results shared with
their primary care provider and also to
participate in the DNA Bank and database
those that opt in will receive either a
positive or negative report I'll say
more about that at the moment if a
positive finding occurs genetic
counseling is offered
we do offer telemedicine counseling for
individuals realizing it's a pretty
large state and won't always be
convenient for people to come to
Birmingham or Huntsville which is where
our kind of main operations are located
providers get a CME program which we
hope will help them understand better
how genomics can be you
used in their practice if the
participant has opted into providing a
report to the provider this is then sent
to them and we do offer point of care
support when a positive result has been
returned these are do posters that have
been prepared which gives you an idea of
the kind of information that is provided
to the population it shows first some of
the contact information individuals now
can sign up through our website to
participate in the program and this
gives a very quick rundown of the basic
sort of nuts and bolts of the program to
enroll through a blood sample that is
obtained and then the DNA is extracted
and tested those that are found to carry
a actionable result will be provided
counseling and then there is a research
component of this that individuals
cannot get to as well these are two
pictures of the enrollment team and a
table set up right outside the
phlebotomy area in the Kirkland clinic
which is the main outpatient clinic at
UAB medical towers as a research
facility at UAB and we're in process of
expanding recruitment to various other
sites especially Huntsville Montgomery
and Selma and we're also setting up
pop-up clinics around the state we
actually did one about a month I said
I'd say ago at the State House to give
state legislators and staff an
opportunity to enroll if they're
interested and we also have a variety of
outreach activities including
participant stories both in video in
print form there is a formal participant
engagement process dr. Sarah Knight is
the leader of that effort it includes
these three components an advisory
committee
consisting of various stakeholders
including participants clinicians health
system executives and community leaders
on that meet on a regular basis and
provide ongoing feedback there are a set
of structured key informant interviews
through communities in the region and
then a facilitated deliberative process
where both our findings and our
approaches to enrollment are reviewed
this is intended to be kind of a way of
getting feedback on whether the way
we're doing this is most appropriate for
the community dr. Steven show decayed
from Tuskegee University has also been a
consultant in the process to help us to
be sure that we're doing things in a
culturally sensitive way in the
community so as mentioned we're in
process of expanding this to multiple
sites
I'm also Mobile Alabama through the
University of South Alabama are intended
to be brought into the program really
one of the main reasons for doing this
is to maximize the diversity of
participants realizing it's a relatively
large state and we certainly can't
expect people to drive across the state
in Birmingham to participate and so
we're trying our best to make us as
broadly available as we can this is a
breakdown of the enrollment so far and
it compares it to um US Census and I
won't go through every number on this
table I realize it's a busy table but
our fundamental goal is to try our best
to reflect the racial and ethnic
diversity of the state and to try to
engage people across as broad a
population as possible and this is
obvious here we have a ways to go we are
nowhere close to having recruited
individuals for example from the
african-american population in
proportion to their representation in
the state we certainly recognize
and that's one of the major motivations
for us to be expanding our enrollment
beyond Birmingham into areas of the
state where some of the populations that
might otherwise be at risk of
participating are most likely to get
their medical care and hopefully to be
willing to participate
we also are aware that we have a higher
proportion of female than male
participants the other thing that we're
trying to address we have done a kind of
rough ancestry analysis it's a somewhat
hard thing to see but the plus symbols
are participants in this principal
components analysis from our study and
the dots are showing populations of
various components and then we have
sampled pretty broad diversity of
populations but not yet to the numbers
that we really know that we need to
achieve if you look at the age breakdown
and this is looking over last year's
time we haven't analyzed the data so far
from this year the peak age as you can
see is from about 50 to 70 and I think
that may reflect in part the phenomenon
of beginning the recruitment in a
medical outpatient clinic and it also
reflects what I think is probably
happening for many people is that they
do see value and the return of results
but they see it as much for their
families as for themselves so let me
show you a little bit about the progress
that has been made so far if we focus
first on the population cohort as of
within the last few weeks 1,500
approximately have been enrolled most
not quite all of those have gone all the
way through the analytic pipeline and so
far pathogenic or likely pathogenic
actually variants have been confirmed in
15 and we have verification and process
for an additional 12 so that means
potentially 27 variants unconfirmed it
may be fewer
in the event that some of the ones that
are in process of verification do not
verify so at least 15 possibly as many
as 27 and if you look at that from the
perspective of percentages if it's only
15 that would be a 1% rate of return and
if all 27 verify it would be about a 1.8
percent rate of return this is in range
for what we anticipated we originally
were estimating between 1 and 3 percent
of participants would have a return of
results of a pathogenic or likely
pathogenic variant in one of the ACMG 59
genes we knew that we were under
ascertaining variants because the global
screening array does not pick up all
possible pathogenic variants so we think
we're actually just about where we
predicted we would be based on the
experience with other studies that we
used to estimate these numbers now
here's the same list I showed you a few
minutes ago but now I've highlighted in
red the examples of genes where there
have been confirmed pathogenic or likely
pathogenic findings now these numbers
are not as large as the numbers I showed
you just a minute ago and the reason is
there have been several examples of
multiple findings in the same gene in
different individuals
so in other words some of these genes
are counted more than one time that's
not indicated on the slide but as you
can see we've had both brca1 and 2 mlh1
a few genes for cardiomyopathy several
for hypercholesterolemia and a couple
actually for malignant hyperthermia this
is actually just looking at the
confirmed ones doesn't count the list of
others that are in process currently
being verified now what you're looking
at here is a screen shot of just one
paragraph from a negative reach
results notification so anybody who
participates adopts in for testing would
get a letter back that tells them that
either we didn't find anything that we
believed to be pathogenic or likely
pathogenic or that we did the area that
we've been most concerned about is in
what I guess you could describe as false
reassurance from a negative result
honestly it's it's or it's not easy to
return a positive result to somebody
because it it has significant medical
implications but in some ways it's
straightforward because it's the kind of
thing we do all the time and people are
doing this in the hope that they will
learn something that they don't want of
course to have an abnormal result but
they're doing it because if they did
they want to know it our biggest worry
is that people will over interpret a
negative result and first of all it
could be interpreted by them to imply
that if we didn't find anything they
must have a clean bill of health
maybe in general or maybe just for the
genes in question and neither of those
is true as I'm sure you recognize when
we're testing only a small subset of
genes many many different kinds of
genetic conditions are not included
first of all and second of all the
coverage of variants even in the genes
we're testing is not 100% and one of the
important points that we make in the
consent process and the education and
outreach process and in the return of
results process is that if you have any
clinical indication for being tested for
example a family history of cancer might
be such an indication or personal
history even the Nghi is not the place
to go to get clinical testing might seem
attractive because it's done free of
charge but it's not a good idea because
this is nowhere near as good coverage as
would be offered if clinical testing
over time
so we've settled on this
wording in the set of genes tested we
did not find any gene differences or
changes that have been linked to a high
risk to develop a disease whoever this
does not mean that you will not develop
any disease in the future it also does
not rule out having a genetic risk
factor for disease even in the genes we
tested so this is an area that we're
definitely concerned about another point
relevant to this is how often do people
choose to share information with their
primary care provider and this is at the
time of initial consent it surprised us
a little bit although in retrospect
maybe it's not that surprising only half
have consented to share the results with
their provider and we think the reason
why is that they want to manage those
results at their discretion and in
particular I guess if there's a positive
result they want the opportunity to
think this through and then to share it
under you know sort of in their own time
and in their own way I can tell you that
if somebody has a positive result we
counseled them and we'll definitely
encourage them to connect with a health
provider who can work with them on a
risk certain management protocol and
usually that will eventually involve
sharing it with the provider but many
prefer to defer that decision until
after they get a result meanwhile 93% as
of the end of last year at least and
consented for their DNA to be saved in
the biobank so there was a very high
uptake of interest in that back to the
point about concerns about people over
interpreting the data we also collect
some basic family history information
that is reviewed by a team of genetic
counselors on all participants they are
specifically reviewing these to
determine if there are red flags in the
family history that might suggest a
familial risk and therefore that the
individual would benefit
from a more formal medical genetics
consultation and if appropriate from for
regular clinical genetic testing so in
looking at the individuals over this
1,500 or so who have been recruited so
far 51 percent so to touch over half had
no findings based on the family history
they provided that would have prompted
us to suggest the genetics consultation
about 5% it wasn't clear-cut but there
was enough suggestion that it was but
worth mentioning to them and a
surprisingly large number 44% they was
recommended additional genetics
consultation because there was
information in the family history that
suggested the possibility of a genetic
etiology for one of these disorders in
spite of the negative tests with the
global screening ready so it's a pretty
reasonable number and I guess you know
one question is taste into judges how
often will these individuals actually
see formal genetics consultation that's
one of the questions we'll be studying
we know that some for sure have but we
don't know yet how many have and again
this becomes a kind of teachable moment
for the community to get their attention
and recognize the potential power of
review of the family history turning
attention now to the whole genome
sequencing 37 Pro bands have been in
rolls of 32 of these who had completed
their sequencing that doesn't mean 37
sequences because many of these are
trios of a parent I'm sorry of a child
and both parents but in any case 37 Pro
bands 32 have been fully analyzed as it
stands right now 8 I'm sorry 1111 had
reportable findings 8 variants of
unknown significance for likely
pathogenic 1 pathogenic now these
numbers may not seem entirely not
because we've had one that was a
secondary finding
also from the ACM k9 list but not a
diagnosis that explained the phenotype
but a secondary finding in somebody who
had opted in to receiving those when
they were two individuals with two what
we would describe as primary findings
that we believe are related to the
underlying theme that's why there's more
findings individually than individuals
who had reportable finals
well we're into the second year and well
into it at this point and I mentioned
already some of our goals one to expand
enrollment particularly to areas of the
state where we believe individuals who
had otherwise be at risk of being
underrepresented in biomedical research
will have a chance to participate we
very much do want to reflect the
demographics of the population in our
state we actually have recorded now some
originally podcasts and videos on
genomic medicine which is intended for
continuing medical education through the
UAB MD Learning Channel our community
engagement efforts continue and
similarly our bio banking efforts
continue and that we'll be having a
symposium in just a few weeks just an
annual event between UAB and HudsonAlpha
and formulating working groups there to
look at with population functional
genomics and then the sort of common
disorders and ethical legal and social
implications can be studied based on
this cohort so me just broadly mentioned
a few kind of lessons that we feel we've
learned over the course of time the
first concerns what I guess could be
considered the value of participation
from the perspective of participants but
it's very clear from the feedback we've
gotten that people are highly
to participate in this and they really
do value the opportunity to get return
of results even realizing many of the
limitations that are being clearly
delineated in the informed consent
document including by the way
uncertainty about pathogen about excuse
me about penetrance in different
populations we've talked about adding
other things ancestry data carrier
status and pharmacogenetic data that
hasn't happened just yet I mean means to
be seeing whether we will the ancestry
return we think not a straightforward
thing because I'm creating a really
user-friendly portal for informing
individuals about their ancestry is it's
not a particularly straightforward
application we have discussed the
possibility of partnering with groups
that have invested heavily and I'm
putting together very user friendly
ancestry and Romanian interfaces we
haven't returned carrier status partly
because we're not sure that that will be
as motivating and partly because the
counseling requirements could become
much greater given essentially everybody
we're very hard to portion of people
will be a carrier for something but we
also haven't yet returned
pharmacogenetic data except for the
malignant hypothermia risks I think the
reason here is that the infrastructure
in the state for physicians to manage
pharmacogenetic data really needs first
to be built out if the person is found
to be a carrier let's suppose for a BRCA
variant that's known to be pathogenic
and this is an adult that individual is
going to be offered a program for
surveillance right then and there
it will begin since they're adults at
that point in time per pharmacogenetic
data they may or may not currently be on
a medication that's relevant to whatever
the variant is found and we worry a
little bit that it could be years even
decades before that time
and we're not so sure that the systems
are in place yet to guarantee that those
results will be available when and where
they need that's something we're
actually working on and hope at some
point that we'll be able to add
pharmacogenetic data maybe by returning
it directly to participate and giving
them a part of some sort that they can
show to their provider if they ever need
to be put on a second are some of the
concerns and I've alluded to those one
that we're very anxious to work out is
to make sure that we really are
recruiting a diverse population again
that reflects the state the obvious
issue here is exacerbation of health
disparities that's something we're
seeing the eager to avoid we have worked
hard to first of all do outreach into
the larger population and secondly to be
sure that we're doing this in a
culturally sensitive way the issue of
clinical versus research testing I
bought also alluded to we really want to
make sure that nobody mistakes this for
clinical testing they will get clinical
grade return of results if something is
found but a negative finding here should
not be taken as a clean bill of health
even for the genes that we evaluated and
achieving numbers you know actually so
far our experience has been I'm pretty
positive that not been that difficult to
get people to be interested in the study
and if anything we're concerned that we
may reach a point where we won't be able
to recruit all the people who might be
interested and finally from the point of
view of impact we think this has the
opportunity to raise public awareness
for genomics we likewise see it as a
kind of teachable moment for the
provider population as well as for the
general population the some extent this
may be helpful as what could be thought
of as a model to test some of the
kinds of approaches to population
screening in a state that has more than
its share of medical problems and plenty
of opportunity to try to do good to
enhance the health of our population
I'm going to end it that there are many
many people not all of whom could be
named on this slide who have felt us to
get this program off the ground and to
keep applying Mina Moss is program
director who really is a person that
coordinates complex kind of show won't
name everybody but we have a team of
genetic counselors both at UAB and
HudsonAlpha
Greg Cooper and his team have been doing
the genomic analysis both for genotyping
and we're whole genome sequencing
HudsonAlpha
the enrollment has been spearheaded by
bono Fuad and her team and William curry
has really been instrumental in helping
us get outreach to the primary care
community Jim Cimino has been in charge
of our informatics efforts jeff Edberg
bio banking I mentioned saronite and dr.
show decay and participant engagement we
have as you can see bioethics team and
like OPI is meant by in Greg Martian
with that I will conclude and we'll be
very happy to take any questions well
thank you dr. Corr for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for let's get started
first question is do you recruit both
children and adults to both the
population and the affected cohorts we
are only recruiting adults who can
provide informed consent to the
population cohort
we're at this point not comfortable on a
population screening basis to return
results of adult onset disorders to
children now that's a little different
than when this is done as an incidental
finding in diagnostic testing where it
is offered to children but to do this on
a screening basis we didn't think that
was appropriate at least not right now
certainly something we can rethink over
time but so the population cohort are
only for adults
in contrast the affected cohort
individuals who have phenotype that
hasn't been diagnosed so far this does
include both children and adults
obviously the parents are asked to
provide consent if possible the child by
essent
but that affected cohort are individuals
thank you what kind of information do
you collect about family and medical
history from participants in the
population cohort right now the
population cohort includes a
questionnaire that targets the kind of
family history that might be related to
the 59 genes that were testing so
specifically questions about individual
or family history of various forms of
cancer of cardiovascular disease sudden
death of adverse reaction anesthesia
hypercholesterolemia things of that sort
we do have for those that opted in the
opportunity to link to an electronic
health record if it's available then
that provides a much broader access to
medical information but what we
specifically asked we've tried to keep
it relatively simple and about some time
consuming it's really meant to flag
individuals who would benefit from
standard genetic testing and not to have
them be sort of lulled into complacency
that no return of results from a GHI
means they don't have a genetic disorder
so as I mentioned earlier those are
wrong
by our team of genetic counselors and
many of them would get a letter saying
that there were some red flags here that
thank you
for the population cohort do you plan to
reanalyze data in the future and
recontact participants if new
information is available this is a
really important issue and the answer
actually is no we don't it's certainly
possible I guess you could say even
probable that over the course of time a
variant will be reclassified we may
learn that things that were not thought
to be pathogenic but discovered to be
pathogenic agood here we go the other
way I supposed to although likely I
think furthermore the ACMG list may be
expanded or at some point we may decide
on her own to expend a list and so the
person who was tested safe with the 59
genes two or three years from now maybe
we'll be testing 75 genes and those
wouldn't have been covered originally
but in the consent process we make it
clear that we're really not set up to be
able to do that kind of recontact
because this is a population wide cohort
we have no way of being sure that we'll
be able to find individuals a year or
two out we are not necessarily providing
the health care and our concern was if
we may they promised to do that there
could be many instances where we would
find it very difficult to locate people
and didn't seem appropriate so what we
say instead is that anybody who
participates is invited to recontact us
if they would like to ask the question
is there anything new and if they do
then we are prepared to do reanalysis
but it really needs to be initiated by
them because otherwise we're afraid that
we'll set up expectations that are just
impossible for us to thank you how do
you decide whom to sequence in the
effected cohort there's a set of
criteria that we use to determine
eligibility
sequencing in the affected cohort it
includes
the kind of things a medical geneticist
might look for in an individual or the
complex phenotype multi-system signs
chronicity course family history would
be a strong indicator although you
realize many of these issues will be de
novo so it's not it's not an algorithm
that's cast in stone it's it's a
judgment we actually have a committee
that reviews the case histories of
individuals who are identified usually
through their primary care doctors or
through the UAB undiagnosed diseases
program or in Huntsville HudsonAlpha
Smith Family Clinic and if their
individuals deemed to be potentially
eligible for screening we have a team of
medical geneticists to review the
clinical history and the family history
and thank you position as to whether an
individual is likely to benefit then be
also sequencing thank you we have time
for one more question
how are family members informed of
potential risk if an individual in the
population cohort receives the results
of a pathogenic variant we don't have on
our own the ability to directly contact
family members due to the obvious
privacy and consent issues so our only
kind of line of communication is
directly to the participant however
anybody who receives a return of results
that indicates a potentially pathogenic
variant is provider or at least offers
genetic counseling either by phone
telemedicine or in-person and of course
there we will emphasize the importance
of notifying relatives if it's a trait
which often will be that could affect
other members of a family a high
proportion of these are dominant and may
very well be a family history known or
unknown to the participant at that point
in time so we obviously can't go around
the participant directly in
family members but we educate the
participant and we also are prepared to
sort of arm them if you will with
information that they can use to
identify relatives and provide them for
example we'll provide them a letter that
explains what's been found that they can
give to a relative with contact
information for how they can get in
touch with us or local genetic counselor
medical geneticist perhaps to have
further testing so that's a important
point we recognize it has to be done
sensitively and with respect for the
privacy of the individual but we
certainly do educate them and try as
best we can to facilitate that well I
would like to once again thank dr. Corr
for his presentation I would also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcasts possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 10th
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please show
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye